le pouvoir d'achat des salariés ils sont
12 millions en france le pouvoir d'achat
est stable c'est ce que révèle le
rapport annuel du centre d'études des
revenus et des coûts le cercle entre 85
et 88 l'augmentation des rémunérations
pour les salariés rémunération nette a
été inférieure à 0,5 pour cent en
revanche les revenus du capital
ceux des prestataires de services les
coiffeurs par exemple des commerçants
des professions de santé ont nettement
progressé
voici deux exemples extrêmes premier
exemple comment vit un couple de
smicards aujourd'hui reportage
d'elisabeth et gelé et françois granier
madame chic et oui travaille dans une
imprimerie son mari soudeur mais
actuellement au chômage donc plus qu'un
salaire qui depuis quatre ans n'a pas
évolué l'année 85 gagné trois mineurs
non 4300 alors les cotisations segmente
et la vie est plus chère ou y voilà
actuellement vous avez combien pour vivo
font tout pour moi oh oui mais feront
face à wimille front comme ça ça vient
quoi mais à la fin du mois voire faut
payer 2000 francs de loyer
le crédit tout ça bon tout ce qui nous
reste à faire c'est de recommencer le
moins 0 les salaires qui stagnent
ils les ressentent comme une injustice
insupportable c'est parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas été augmentés depuis six
ans que monsieur chikhaoui a quitté son
emploi et même au chômage il ne le
regrette pas